I like to exercise,
but the time it takes up in my day
bothers me.
The time I spend running,
I could be doing anything else on one of
these days.
A thought occurred to me,
putting aside for a moment,
the ancillary benefits of exercise,
like energy,
physique,
mental clarity,
et cetera.
Do the life length and benefits you get
from exercising outweigh the time you
spend doing it?
Well,
let's find out.
So according to a study in 2012
published in the peer reviewed BMJ that
included over 650,000
participants,
moderate exercise,
like briskly walking,
cycling,
etc.
For 2.5
hours per week,
we'll add on average 3.4
to 4.5
years to your life.
But how many hours is that?
If you live 3.4
years longer,
which is the low end of what we'd
expect,
that means that you've gained 30,000
hours.
But not all of that is productive time
because you have to sleep accounting for
that.
You've gained 20,000
but you have to spend time to get this
reward.
So let's say you work out for your
entire adult life starting at 20 years
old and he lived to be 80 so you've been
working out 2.5
hours per week for 60 years.
That comes out to a total cost of 7,800
hours.
So what does this mean?
Well,
it means the way we think about
exercising is wrong.
You weren't spending time exercising.
You're actually creating time for every
hour you spend exercising.
You'll get 2.5
hours on the back end of your life.
So don't feel bad going to the gym or
stealing a few minutes for a walk.
Not only will you get that hour back to
spend at the office,
but you're also going to get extra time
to spend with friends and family.
Now,
obviously this isn't the secret to
eternal youth.
There are diminishing returns on this,
so don't run down the street thinking
that you've cheated death.
But let's say that you're one of the 80%
of Americans,
80% of British,
60% of Australian adults or anyone in
the developed world who doesn't get to
wait five hours of exercise a week.
It's not that you don't have time to
exercise.
Actually the reverse is true.
You can't afford not to.
Okay.